Дорогі друзі!
Сьогодні ми починаємо з вами
вивчати розділ «Квантова фізика».
Я Сіпій Володимир Володимирович,
кандидат педагогічних
наук, вчитель вищої категорії,
спеціалізована школа №2 імені Дмитра
Карбишева Подільського району м.Києва.
Тема сьогоднішнього нашого заняття
«Квантові властивості світла.
Квантові постулати Бора».
На попередніх заняттях ви познайомилися
з електромагнітною природою світла.
Безпосередньо світло у нас являє
собою електромагнітну хвилю -
взаємно перпендикулярні у просторі
вектори напруженості електричного поля
та індукції магнітного поля.
Хвильові явища вам вже знайомі.
Запитання до глядачів.
Правильна відповідь
Давайте згадаємо ці явища.
Явище інтерференції всім
нам знайоме з дитинства.
Наприклад, це мильна бульбашка.
Явище
дифракції
теж практично кожен з нас спостерігав,
бачачи поверхню оптичного диску.
Явище дисперсії світла – коли при
проходженні через трикутну призму
ми утворюємо веселку, або спектр.
Явище поляризації світла
не викликає поділ білого
світла на різні кольори,
але активно використовується
для того, щоб зменшити світло,
що потрапляє в очі зустрічного водія.
Згадайте як.
Випромінювання хвиль під час
прискореного руху електронів відбувається.
Ми вже знайомі з принципами радіозв’язку:
безпосередньо електромагнітна хвиля
утворюється в передавальній антені
при прискореному руху електронів в ній.
Хвильова теорія світла не могла
пояснити випромінювання світла атомом.
Як вам відомо з курсу фізики,
перша модель атома, що була запропонована
– це модель атома Джосефа Джона Томсона,
яка являла собою, фактично,
пудинг з родзинками,
де рівномірно в просторі розміщені
позитивні та негативні заряди.
Негативними зарядами в нас є електрони.
На зміну цій моделі
прийшла модель атома Ернеста Резерфорда,
де в центрі атома знаходиться
невеличке ядро, розміром близько
1О у мінус 15 степені м (метрів).
Навколо цього ядра по
орбіталям рухаються електрони.
Розмір орбіталі 1О у
мінус 1О степені м (метрів).
Теорія будови атома Резерфорда
увійшла в суперечність з електромагнітною
теорією походження світла,
тому що під час
прискореного руху електронів,
а електрони в нас рухаються по орбіталям,
тобто – наявне доцентрове прискорення,
вони мали б випромінювати світло.
Насправді цього не відбувалося.
Цю теорію удосконалив Нільс Бор.
При переході лише з одного
енергетичного рівня на інший
відбувається випромінювання кванта світла.
Обидві ці теорії використовуються, вони не
втратили актуальність з розвитком науки,
оскільки вони є узагальненням
експериментальних фактів.
В основі теорії Бора
лежить гіпотеза Планка, що:
світло випромінюється та
поглинається порціями, квантами.
Енергію кванта світла можна
обчислити за відповідною формулою,
її ви бачите на екрані
де h – це стала Планка.
Квантові постулати Бора,
що були сформульовані.
Перший постулат – про стаціонарні стани.
Його ви бачите на екрані.
Другий постулат – про квантові стрибки.
Зверніть увагу на малюнок.
Ви бачите, що якщо атом переходить
від зовнішньої орбіталі до внутрішньої –
квант світла випромінюється
(зелений колір).
Якщо квант світла атомом поглинається
(зображено червоним кольором)
то електрон в атомі
переходить на вищу орбіталь.
Третій постулат Бора – радіуси
стаціонарних станів задовольняють умові:
добуток маси електрона на швидкість
електрона на відповідній орбіті
та на її радіус
дорівнює
добутку
номера орбіталі на сталу
Планка, поділену на 2 Пі.
Як ви бачите, тут іде мова про
розрахунки з числами
у стандартному вигляді.
Тому нам необхідно буде
скористатися калькулятором.
Ви можете взяти калькулятор
або спеціальний прилад,
або скористатися своїм
смартфоном чи комп’ютером.
Ми при розв’язуванні задач
будемо користуватися комп’ютером.
Одиниці енергії у
ядерній та квантовій фізиці
дещо відрізняються від
звичних для нас одиниць енергії
в інших розділах фізики.
Оскільки мова йде про дуже малі величини,
то енергію подають в
“еВ” (електрон-вольтах).
Звертаю вашу увагу, що одиниця
Дж (джоуль) пишеться з великої літери,
тому що вона названа
на честь вченого Джоуля,
а еВ (електрон-вольт): “В” – велика літера
(це вчений Вольт), “е” – маленька літера.
Взаємозв’язок між цими
одиницями перед вами на екрані.
Сталу Планка ми теж можемо
показати або в еВ (електрон-вольтах),
якщо нам потрібно отримати
енергію кванта в електрон-вольтах,
або у Дж (джоулях), якщо ми
розв’язуємо задачу в основних одиницях СІ.
Зробимо відповідне перетворення.
Стала Планка
дорівнює 6,625
на 1О у мінус 34 степені
джоуля на секунду.
Якщо нам необхідно
перевести в еВ (електрон-вольти)
то нам відповідне значення треба поділити
на 1,6 на 1О у мінус 19 степені.
Тобто,
в чисельнику в нас буде
6,625 на 1О у мінус 34 степені,
в знаменнику
відповідний коефіцієнт переведення
1,6 на 1О у мінус 19 степені.
Результат у нас буде вже в
електрон-вольтах за секунду.
Розв’яжемо кілька задач на
закріплення вивченого матеріалу
і на застосування теорії
до розв’язування задач.
Перша задача.
Умови задачі на екрані.
Ми дізналися про першу фізичну величину,
можемо її записати до умови задачі
Довжина хвилі в нас
позначається літерою “Лямбда”.
Вона дорівнює 490 нм (нанометри).
Десяткова приставка нано
означає 1О у мінус 9 степені.
Тому ми можемо написати,
що це 490 на 1О у мінус 9 степені метра.
Або у вигляді
стандартного числа – це буде
4,9 на 1О у мінус сьомому степені метра.
Що ж нас запитують?
Нас запитують: наскільки
зменшилась енергія атому?
Справді, при випромінюванні
світла енергія атома зменшується.
Розрахувати це значення ми можемо
за вивченою на цьому уроці формулою –
енергія дорівнює добутку
сталої Планка на частоту.
Відповідь подати у
електрон-вольтах та джоулях.
Відділяємо те, що відомо, від того,
що знайти, та починаємо розв’язання.
Основна формула, яку
використовуємо – це: енергія
дорівнює добутку сталої Планка на частоту
(формулу ви бачите на екрані)
Але в нас частота невідома.
Проте, ми знаємо формулу
зв’язку частоти з довжиною хвилі,
яка у нас входить в умову задачі
Відповідно,
частота
дорівнює:
швидкість світла поділити на довжину хвилі
(формулу ви бачите на екрані).
Підставивши формулу для розрахунку частоти
у формулу для розрахунку енергії,
згадавши, що якщо випромінюється
або поглинається квант
відбувається зміна енергії атома
(ця формула відповідає енергії
кванта E=hv), а нас питають зміну.
По суті, це одне й те саме
числове значення, проте – різні речі.
Це (E=hv) – енергія кванта.
Це – зміна енергії атому.
Але вони рівні між собою.
Тому ми можемо записати:
дельта Е дорівнює
hc поділене на лямбду
(формулу ви бачите на екрані).
Наступний крок розв’язання задачі –
ми підставляємо чисельні значення.
Дельта Е дорівнює.
У нас в умову задачі
стала Планка не входить.
Це фізична стала.
Її, навіть під час зовнішнього
незалежного оцінювання, ви зможете
знайти у своєму тестовому зошиті,
то і запам’ятовувати її недоцільно.
Звичайно, бажано – чим більше запам’ятає
людина, тим краще розвинеться її пам’ять.
Тим паче, ви її розвиваєте,
навчаючись у школі.
Це якраз той фізіологічний вік,
коли пам’ять треба тренувати.
Тому, якщо можете – запам’ятовуємо.
Ні – запишіть це на аркуші
і використовуйте під
час розв’язування задач.
Стала Планка (h) в нас 6,625
на 1О у мінус 34 степені
(формулу ви бачите на екрані).
Одиницю ми не вказуємо.
Розрахунок з одиницями фізичної
величини проведемо окремо.
Далі ми множимо ще на одну фізичну
сталу – це швидкість світла у вакуумі:
3 на 1О у 8 степені.
І поділити на те значення,
що в нас відомо в умові задачі.
І це значення нам бажано
подавати в стандартному вигляді:
4,9 на 1О у мінус 7 степені
дорівнює.
Цей розрахунок усно виконати неможливо,
тому ми маємо скористатися
допомогою калькулятора.
Скористаємось ним.
Вчитель вносить дані для
розрахунку в калькулятор.
Зробивши відповідний розрахунок,
ми отримуємо значення енергії:
4 цілих 6 сотих
на 1О у мінус 19 степені.
(Значення ви бачите на екрані).
Оскільки ми використовували
сталу Планка в джоулях за секунду,
то результат у нас буде у джоулях (Дж).
Переконаємось у цьому.
Проведемо розрахунок
одиниць фізичної величини
(формулу ви бачите на екрані).
Зміна енергії: стала Планка в чисельнику –
це джоуль помножити на секунду,
помножити швидкість
світла (метри за секунду)
і довжина хвилі – метри.
(Як провести розрахунок –
ви можете бачити на екрані).
Секунди і секунди у нас
взаємно скорочуються.
Також у нас скорочуються метри.
І виходить, що одиницею
вимірювання у нас є джоуль.
Це лише частина розв’язання цієї задачі.
Друга частина.
Нам цей результат, який
ми отримали у джоулях,
треба перетворити в електрон-вольти.
Для цього потрібно скористатися
відомим нам співвідношенням:
поділити отриманий результат у джоулях
на: 1,6 на 1О у мінус 19 степені.
(Як провести розрахунок –
ви можете бачити на екрані)
Таким чином дельта Е дорівнює –
для цього нам достатньо лише
поділити (4,06 на 1О у мінус 19 степені)
на 1,6 на 1О у мінус 19 степені.
Множник 1О у мінус 19 входить і
до чисельника, і до знаменника.
Тому вони взаємно знищуються
і в нас залишилось 4,06 поділити на 1,6.
Виконаємо відповідну дію.
(Як провести розрахунок –
ви можете бачити на екрані).
Результат у нас = 2,54
а одиницею фізичної величини
буде електрон-вольт (еВ).
Нагадую, що якщо ми під час розрахунків
не вказували одиниці фізичної величини,
то результат (одиницю) ми беремо в дужки.
Якщо вказували – дужки не використовували.
Умови наступної задачі
ви бачите на екрані.
Давайте згадаємо -
що таке явище йонізації?
Явище йонізації – це коли в нас з
нейтрального атома утворюється йон.
При тому, йони в нас
бувають позитивні і негативні.
Якщо у нас відбувається
поглинання фотона –
поглинання кванту світла,
то, швидше за все,
у нас відбулося явище,
коли атом втратив електрон.
І це йонізація
Йонізований атом у нас
матиме позитивний заряд,
тому що електрон у нас
відірвано (негативний заряд).
Енергія – 14,5 еВ.
Ми можемо одразу в умові задачі
перетворити це значення в джоулі,
якщо подальші розрахунки ми
будемо проводити в системі СІ.
Для того, щоб перевести у джоулі,
нам потрібно помножити
на коефіцієнт переведення:
1,6 на 1О у мінус 19 степені.
Знову ж таки, цей розрахунок
раджу виконувати на калькуляторі.
Повторюйте за мною: не
записувати, а зробіть те, що і я.
Відкриваємо калькулятор.
У нас буде просто добуток двох величин.
Обов’язково розберіться,
як на вашому калькуляторі
ввести стандартний вигляд числа,
тобто – число виду:
1,6 помножити на 1О у мінус 19 степені.
Це зручно – одразу
ввести з степінню числа 1О,
тому результат в цьому випадку ми теж
отримаємо у стандартному вигляді числа.
До речі, зверніть увагу на запис.
У нас записано: 2,32,
далі йде літера Е мінус 18.
(Результат ви бачите на екрані).
Оця літера Е
означає помножити на 1О у мінус 18.
Хто цікавиться інформатикою,
активно програмує,
чи користується табличним процесором –
з цим вже неодноразово зустрічався.
До речі, ці розрахунки можна зробити
і за допомогою табличного процесора,
можна за допомогою мови програмування,
але простіше – за допомогою
інженерного калькулятора.
Запишемо цей результат.
Ви бачите його на екрані:
2,32
помножити на 1О у мінус 18 степені Дж.
Зверніть увагу,
справді ж 14,5 легше
сприймається і запам’ятовується,
ніж цей величезний вираз,
Саме тому, що мікросвіт у
нас працює з малими енергіями,
зустірчаються там малі енергії,
і використовується електрон-вольт
для описання цих процесів.
Повернімося до умови нашої задачі –
визначити довжину хвилі,
яка спричинила йонізацію.
Довжина хвилі позначається лямбда.
Формула, про яку йдеться – та
сама, що і в попередній задачі.
Можемо її запам’ятати одразу вже
з лямбдою, але це трапляється,
коли вже розв’язав не одну таку задачу,
відпрацював цей навчальний матеріал.
Головне – пам’ятати ті вихідні
формули, з яких легко це вивести.
Увага на екран!
Це енергія кванта
hν
(добуток сталої Планка на частоту).
І друга формула – це як
частота пов’язана з довжиною,
тому що для електромагнітних хвиль,
як правило, йде мова про їх
характеристики – і частота, і довжина.
Тобто,
В техніці,
мабуть п’ятдесят на п’ятдесят
зустрічаються або частота (наприклад,
частота радіостанції 100 мегагерц),
або довжина хвилі
(наприклад, телевізійний канал працює в
метровому, або дециметровому діапазоні).
Формула, про яку я вам нагадував
(ви бачите її на екрані) - це частота,
яка дорівнює швидкість світла
поділити на довжину хвилі.
Підставляємо з першої формули
в другу значення для частоти.
Отримуємо вираз,
що ви зараз бачите.
Аналогічний вираз ми
вивели в попередній задачі.
Але нас запитують – чому
дорівнює довжина (лямбда)?
Робимо відповідне
алгебраїчне перетворення.
Зараз ви його бачите
Лямбда дорівнює hc (добуток сталої Планка
на швидкість світла), поділити на енергію.
Наступний крок – числовий розрахунок.
Підставляємо числові значення
цих величин – ви бачите це на екрані:
чисельник у нас – стала Планка (6,625)
помножити
помножити на 1О у мінус 34 степені,
помножити на 3 на 1О у 8 степені –
це значення швидкості світла.
В знаменнику – значення
енергії кванту випромінювання,
який йонізував цей атом,
тобто – вирвав у нього електрон.
Знову ж таки,
для проведення цього розрахунку
раджу скористатися калькулятором,
що ми і зробимо зараз разом з вами.
Увага на екран! Ви бачите,
як проходить розрахунок.
В результаті цього
розрахунку ми маємо значення,
що ви бачите на екрані: 8,57
на 1О у мінус 8 степені метра.
Зверніть увагу,
що внаслідок розрахунку
ми не отримали рівно 8,57.
Ми отримали дріб, який продовжується.
Справа в тому, що фізика,
як наука експериментальна, традиційно
працює з наближеними значеннями величин.
Записувати всі ці знаки при
розв’язанні задач не є доцільним.
Навіть у тесті зовнішнього
незалежного оцінювання,
коли вас просять записати результат –
пишуть з точністю до
скількох знаків після коми.
Якби нам потрібно було записати з
точністю до трьох знаків після коми,
ми б отримали значення 8,567.
Чому 567 тисячних?
Згадаємо правило округлення:
якщо після того знаку, що ми округлюємо,
число 5 і більше, то ми
його збільшуємо на 1.
Якщо ж число від 4 до 0,
то ми нічого не збільшуємо, а просто
відкидаємо решту знаків, що обчислюємо.
Ось і пролунав дзвоник.
Дзвоник – час для відпочинку.
До наступних зустрічей в ефірі!
І не забудьте про домашні завдання.
Переконайтесь, що
почуте на уроці ви засвоїли.